hi
welcome to another episode of cold
fusion
the latest iphone the iphone 14 has just
been announced while the focus is on
what new features may or may not have
been added there's a lot to be said
about the story of how an iphone is made
from european chip manufacturing
machines to taiwanese critical
components it really is a global effort
to put one of these devices in your hand
since the beginning china has been the
go-to place to manufacture the iphone
but lately due to potential signs of
instability in china apple is
increasingly looking towards india to
pick up some of that manufacturing
capability let's take a look at what's
going
are watching on fusion tv
[Music]
so to begin why was china the place that
was selected to manufacture the iphone
well let me tell you a little story
as detailed in my book in 2007 steve
jobs decided to have a glass screen
instead of plastic for the first iphone
he made this decision just weeks before
its launch but what i didn't write was
how this was achieved
american companies said that this last
minute switch was impossible however a
chinese factory said that they could do
it they constructed a dormitory
beforehand so their workers could work
12-hour shifts when the contract was
signed with apple 8 000 workers were
woken up from sleep given a biscuit and
tea and then got to work fitting the
glass screen to the iphone to in the end
produce 10 000 iphones per day
if this work was done in the united
states one it would be much more
expensive and two it would take a few
months to gather all the workers while
in china it only took a few days
leaving aside the obvious human rights
issues stories like this highlight why
china is dubbed the world's factory and
why the iphone is mostly made there but
as mentioned recently things have begun
to swing towards india
[Music]
apple first started manufacturing
iphones in india in 2017 with the iphone
se
since then apple has been working with
suppliers to ramp up manufacturing in
india and now it's picking up the pace
in 2020 india was making 1.5 of global
iphone supply currently the country
accounts for about five percent of
supply with the iphone 14 in 2022 apple
wants to race this to seven percent
that's around 12 million iphones
earlier this year apple even started
making the iphone 13 in india
last month apple analyst ming chi kuo
stated that iphone 14 production would
begin in india six weeks after beginning
in china
usually this lag would be six to nine
months it's believed that iphone 15
production next year will begin
simultaneously in both countries
and the indian government has offered
financial incentives for tech production
they call this scheme the make in india
program
foxconn the primary manufacturer of
iphones studied the process of shipping
components from china and assembling the
iphone 14 at a plant in the indian city
of chennai in the south for now this is
likely how the supply chain will work
while this may be good news for india
there are still three main hurdles to
overcome
number one there is a huge supply chain
network in china which doesn't exist in
india
it would take a lot of investment to get
a parallel indian system to a comparable
state
assembling iphones often entails
coordination between hundreds of
suppliers and this isn't to mention
apple's infamously tight deadlines and
strict quality control
number two
for apple there's a great deal of risk
when it comes to security and secrecy
when moving to a new country
apple goes to extreme lengths to keep
new product details confidential and to
stop leaks
imposing the same rigorous controls in a
second country would prove to be very
difficult
local foxconn executives in india have
thought about entirely cornering off a
section of one of foxconn's assembly
lines
according to bloomberg they placed a
great deal of scrutiny on how security
around the device could be compromised
the conclusion so far it's going to be a
real challenge to replicate the drastic
security controls that the chinese
facilities have
in addition to this also according to
bloomberg apple has major concerns about
indian custom officials they usually
open up packages and check their
contents this is to make sure materials
match their declarations and it goes
without saying that this is a massive
potential vulnerability for product
security
and number three
india's workforce and factories have
caused a bit of a headache for apple
over the past five years they've been
disputes and even revolts over poor
quality food and pay it seems that this
will probably be the easiest issue to
fix improve the facilities and
re-examine wages
so why is apple doing all of this
exactly
well the key word is uncertainty because
of the economic and geopolitical climate
apple sees a need to diversify its
supply chain and build redundancy
they're seeking alternatives as the ccp
clashes with the us government
a visit to taiwan by the speaker for the
us house of representatives nancy pelosi
came at possibly the worst time
it partly destabilized the asia pacific
region at a time when tensions were
already high
harsh lockdowns across china especially
those in the manufacturing hubs have
really disrupted economic activity
these lockdowns as well as u.s sanctions
have put a dent in china's manufacturing
prowess
couple this with rising labor costs in
china and a shaky property market and
it's no wonder apple is starting to look
elsewhere for manufacturing
all goes into apple's strategy of
further diversifying its production
capabilities outside of greater china
but yeah this is a very big move uh and
you know does it mean that apple is
going to move entirely out of china no
but it does see apple hedging its bets
that you know there's potentially bigger
problems coming as far as manufacturing
products there down the line and
obviously this also comes after all
those lockdowns and shutdowns that we've
seen in china hampering manufacturing so
this is apple making a a bet on the fact
that you know they may have to further
diversify
just to kind of get away from these kind
of troubles in the future
so what do you guys think do you think
apple's move will encourage more
investment by other companies to india
feel free to discuss in the comments
section below
anyway that's about it from me my name
is tagogo and you've been watching cold
fusion and i'll catch you again soon for
the next episode
cheers guys
have a good
[Music]
cold fusion
it's new thinking